- If you farted right
now, this entire place
would smell like a garden, alright?
(laughs)
(light music)
- Today we are here at Bia Coffee
in Koreatown, Los Angeles.
- And we are here to try the soon-to-be
world famous flower coffee.
(light jazz music)
What is it?
- It's coffee that apparently tastes like
flower.
- Flowers are delightful,
they're colorful,
they smell nice.
- I actually like dead flowers.
I keep a lot of them in my room.
- Like pressed flowers or
straight up just wilted
dying flowers?
- Just dead.
- We used to have rose bushes,
I'd like try them and I
was always disappointed.
- Never ate a flower but I like 'em.
- Always dreamed about
eating flowers as a kid.
(upbeat music)
- There's so much cool
stuff going on here.
Rosebuds, floating in that.
- Full bud.
- I'm gonna drink it.
Mm.
- Oh!
- That tastes like a rose!
- That's fuckin' crazy.
- Very refreshing.
- I've had some drinks that
have had rose water in it.
- Yeah.
- That doesn't even taste
as much like a rose,
like this does.
- Sometimes cold brew
is too bitter for me.
- Right.
- But this has like that little
floral aftertaste, is really nice.
- You think kinda like they
just taste like plants.
It actually tastes like a rose.
I don't know what that means.
- Evan is just like chugging it.
- Yeah, like, this is so good.
(laughs)
(upbeat music)
- Dang!
This one's so pretty, I
don't wanna mess it up.
- I feel like I am sitting
inside of someone's Instagram.
- I don't wanna stir
it, it looks so pretty.
- Okay, ready?
It's so good.
- It's so good.
- There's like coffee,
some sweetness,
creamy
floral,
gorgeous,
heaven.
- You know sometimes
coffee is just a little
heavy or too strong or whatever?
This is a delight.
- It tastes like a french flower shop.
- This isn't like any
coffee I've had before.
- This is seriously some
freshness going on here.
(upbeat music)
- These drinks
keep getting more and more elaborate.
- Got a little rose petal on it.
And I will.
(laughs)
Delicious.
- I feel so fancy, I
just ate a rose petal.
Who am I?
- Here's a game changer, heaven.
- Are you putting half and half?
- Half and half makes it an Italian soda.
Look at beautiful that is.
- That's so good.
- It's sweet.
- Yeah.
- With that rosy, sort of floral
in your sinuses, coming through.
- Try it with cream.
It's different, right?
Got like a nice smoothness.
- It's a lot better actually.
- I would say it's the sweetest drink
that we've had so far.
- Oh, my God.
- It's good though, it's like
better than any other soda.
- You know you're a
kid and it's New Years.
- Yeah.
- And the adults are drinking champagne,
I think this is what I thought
the champagne tasted like.
And I wish this is what
champagne tasted like.
- Who knew that so many things could be?
Flowers were missing from so many drinks.
- Tastes great and it's pretty?
That's like meeting a guy
who's smart and attractive.
Rare.
(funky music)
- This is like
classy cake.
- This screams luxury to me, look at that.
- Ping.
- Mm.
- It tastes like a flower.
- Damn, I mean, dang.
- It's so light.
- It looks so heavy and
thick but really like it.
- Oh, my God, this one's so good.
- The texture feels a little
bit like a carrot cake.
It's light, fluffy.
- If you like lavender and
you wanna taste lavender,
this is the food you get.
- I could eat that entire thing.
(light music)
- Well, this place is the
greatest place on Earth.
- Very refreshing, I love flower coffee.
- Cold brew with the rose
infusion is just so good.
You chugged yours in like 10 seconds.
- I feel like a princess unicorn
that has a great Instagram.
- I feel like this is going to be the like
the course for my entire wedding.
Like, everyone just gonna drink
and eat flower-infused things forever.
- All of the drinks, all of the cake,
they taste exactly what it smells like.
- It just tasted like
actually what you think
flowers would taste like distilled.
And not like a weird,
syrupy version of it.
- I'm gonna just come
in wearing some shorts
and just be like, "Two of the normals."
(laughs)
What we just had today.
Three drinks and a slice of cake.
- Flowers or no flowers, you know what?
Flowers, just put 'em in stuff.
(upbeat music)